hey there guys thanks for tuning in so
today I'm doing something a little bit
different I've been teasing for a while
now that something awesome and martial
arts related has come to the channel and
finally I'm going to unveil and share
what that is so it's not so much a thing
as it is a person I'm very happy to
introduce a new collaborator on this
channel
Brant Stevens so grant is a martial
artist but he's also an actor
he's also an editor he edited that
awesome teaser trailer that you saw
earlier so he's got very high production
values in his videos he's very
interested in self-development and
discipline and he reads many of the same
books I do so he's a fantastic fit for
this channel and grant was watching some
of the videos and he got in touch to ask
if maybe I'd like to train with him and
at the same time maybe there'd be some
cool work that we could do together
obviously grant could easily kick my ass
so I agreed actually this was really
good timing because I've been wanting to
bring more martial arts related content
to the channel for a while I've just
been looking for the right way to do it
and at the same time I've been toying
around the idea of inviting contributors
to the channel experts in different
fields so that I can make the bio near a
single place on the web where you can
get all kinds of information from a
broad range of experts make it not so
much the bio near as the Bioneers maybe
there's more like this coming stay tuned
I told you we were putting a team
together
who's we
[Music]
grant is a fantastic teacher in just an
hour of training with him I learned more
about martial arts than I think I have
done in many hours of regular training I
feel really privileged to have Grant
contributing to this channel I think you
guys are gonna love his stuff too and
yeah this short little introduction from
the man himself is gonna serve as a
tease of some of the awesome stuff
that's to come so without further ado
I'm very proud to give you Brant Stevens
hi my name is grant Stevens I'm a
martial artist as well as an actor some
of you might have seen me in the KNK
production short film cable chronicles
of Hope in which I played at the mutant
Nightcrawler from the x-men I just want
to start by saying thank you very much
for all of the positive feedback that
you put on the teaser that recently went
up onto the channel
[Music]
how many different interests but without
a doubt the martial arts is the thing
that I love to do the most and recently
I've been exploring a passion to share
those things that I've learned with
people in order to help them with the
physical things like their technique but
also things like the mindset that it
takes to consistently move toward
something of which you're aiming without
getting burned out or tired with the
process I believe that life is somewhat
a reflection of art and by consistently
dedicating yourself to something over an
extended period of time
you begin to draw parallels between that
thing and a very involvement of your
life itself if there's one thing I've
observed consistently with really highly
successful people
it's that dedication to some kind of
creative skill or endeavor that becomes
their own path to mastery of their self
and striving to become all that they can
be so with that being said it gives me
great pleasure to announce that I'm
gonna become a contributor to the
bi-linear channel I'll be sharing
information such as training tips and
also other resources like books and
other information that I think we'll be
able to give you the edge in your
training or whatever endeavor you're
pursuing also if there's any specific
things that you would like me to do a
video about please leave it in the
comments and I'll see what I can do
about that I'm really excited to share
my knowledge with you as a big vision of
mine is to become a person of value in
the world that uses what they've learned
and their experiences in order to help
others grow in the same way I'm also in
the process of developing my own
personal brand called optimum technique
which will focus primarily on martial
arts training and self-improvement I
also have a series of video courses
currently in production in which I break
down in great detail things I've learned
over the years and things that I think
will be able to help you get better as
well and lastly I'd like to thank Adam
for giving me the opportunity to share
this information with you guys on the
channel we met for the first time last
week and spoke about loads of different
ideas of things we'd like to do and also
did some training together as well which
was really good for them so I think
we'll be able to provide a lot of value
for you guys
the coming months with the videos that
we've got planned thank you very much
for watching
[Music]
you